welcome to metaphysical milkshake i am
one of your hosts reza aslan and i am
the lesser of the two hosts rayne wilson
you are not you my friend are a bona
fide celebrity you are a bona fide
celebrity i'm pretty i'm pretty
huge i'm about as big as it gets listen
yeah i loved you and friends i thought
it was great great show oh thanks um
thanks but yeah i just saw this thing i
just saw an announcement you've got a
new show now coming out the geography of
bliss
traveling around the world on peacock's
money
nbc universal is footing the bill
pretending to work but not really cannot
believe for the life of me that they are
paying me
very nice money to travel the world i am
going to syria iceland ghana dubai
thailand and japan and what's the point
the whole point of the show is to search
for happiness why are people happier in
some places and not in others what is it
culturally that we can glean from some
of these far corners of the earth that
can enrich our own lives both you know
individually on a personal level but
culturally as well i mean i would have
paid them don't tell i hope they're not
listening i would have paid them
to go on these travels i mean come on
this is this is the thing you're
you're going around the world trying to
figure out what makes people happy when
what makes you happy is going around the
world it's like yes
and in fact that's not that's not a like
a a fake thing there are numerous
studies numerous studies about how
travel can make you happier can make you
healthier uh can improve your mental
acuity uh it can make you less racist it
can make you less prejudiced like there
is nothing but enormous benefits
to to just traveling in general uh man
this show sounds like a scam to me i got
to be honest with you sounds like a scam
it's a little bit of a scam i have i
have ripped somebody off this is
absolutely incredible welcome to
metaphysical milkshake the show where we
go deep we get weird and we search for
the meaning of life along the way
presented by cast media and soul pancake
i love to be able to
take some of the ideas we've been
exploring on our podcast over the last
year year and a half however many 50
plus 60 plus episodes we've done so far
but you know
mental health that intersection between
mental health uh positive psychology
spirituality sociology and different
kind of cultures and
it is all rooted in
in travel and it is um travel's such an
important component
of that search for happiness you're
exactly right it is in my household it
is in my household your household
is has travel as a as a philosophy do
you have that and is it is it like a
familial contract that you guys sign is
it
kind of a sign yeah it literally is we
have a we have you know a list of our
family values that we have you know on a
wall uh in our den
and
travel is on there and people are like
wait travel is not a value that's a
thing that you do not in the aslan
jackly household for us
travel is is not just a value it's one
of one of the most important values that
we have you know our boys we have two
ten-year-olds now a seven year old and
then a two-year-old two-year-old is a
pandemic baby so she hasn't gone
anywhere yet
but
the uh the you know my other three kids
uh i mean they have been to
dozens and dozens of countries in fact
right the summer before the pandemic
started
my wife and i uh and our three boys
did this insane 80-day
journey around the world we literally
circled the globe
in 80 days
uh together as a family went to
something like 23 different cities now
how old were your kids when you did this
the twins were about to be eight they
were just about to turn eight
and they uh and my youngest son
was about to turn well he was like five
and a half so he was five and a half
years old okay okay so just old enough
to appreciate it because much younger
and they wouldn't have really
well and you know people say that all
the time they're like but you know your
kids they're not going to remember all
of this and it is true i will say that
they're you know
sometimes we'll be watching a movie or
whatever and like it'll be like the
pyramids of giza and i'll be like boys
do you remember when we went inside the
great pyramid of giza and they're like
no
i'm like god damn it
god damn it like how do you not remember
that
um but but what i will say is that
over and beyond the sort of very
specific memories that they have
who they are as human beings
how they see the world how they see
people who are a different color than
them or who speak a different language
or who are different ethnicity or or you
know or different religion how they
interact with people who aren't like
them has been absolutely and i would say
permanently altered
by the experience simply of traveling
around the world and and seeing people
live
different kinds of lives you know it's
it's kind of it's soaked into their skin
it's really made them
i think
i would say better human beings
that's fantastic did you document this
trip at all
we did yes we we
my wife uh blogged uh about it uh
extensively and and uh
and you know and and it was such a
magical time to be honest like we've
we've now decided that we're gonna try
to make this uh a maybe once every five
year
thing you know i mean five years is how
long it'll take me to save up the money
necessary uh in order to try it again
but you know this this brought up this
kind of idea for us your your show
geography of bliss uh my family and and
the way that we think about travel and
what travel can do to a human being how
it can change a person's perspective and
we thought you know this is exactly the
kind of topic that we should have a
podcast about the importance of travel
the um what we can learn from travel
that what
you know
the uh the crucialness of travel in this
time of great
uh disunity and and difficulty and who
better to come along on this
metaphysical journey with us than the
fantastic drew binsky
um this kid is phenomenal he just turned
30 years old and been to every single
country in the world including north
korea
iran malawi any place you can possibly
think of even the super hard to get to
ones um
and
uh he's a travel blogger he's got 10
million subscribers across all of his
platforms he's got two guinness book of
world records
one is for most unesco world heritage
site visits in 24 hours i didn't know
that was something you could get okay
and one is for the fastest time to pack
a suitcase and for a while he was the
youngest person the youngest american
rather to have visited every single
country oh this is exciting okay my you
know my wife tried to do this uh but she
hasn't seen all of them so this is this
is uh this is one for you
baby
drubinsky welcome to the show
rain how you doing
um i couldn't be better drew thanks so
much for coming on metaphysical
milkshake hey drew uh where where in
this great big uh world of ours are you
uh calling in from and you're in your
many many exotic trials no no no let me
guess let me guess macedonia no no no no
no no let me guess madagascar noah
madagascar no no um bhutan
where are you for real i wish i could
tell you something like that but i am in
uh scottsdale arizona where i grew up
i'm in my house
come on
i have good wi-fi here that's why i
decided to take the call now if i was in
bhutan i wouldn't be able to connect you
flew from bhutan to scottsdale in order
to do our podcast thank you drubinski
my first question for you we've got a
lot to uh uncover and dig into and your
story is fascinating how did this begin
how did give us a little about your
biography where did this urge to travel
come from i studied abroad in the czech
republic my junior year of college i
went to university of wisconsin-madison
found a study abroad program i went
there without knowing anybody had an
amazing semester traveled to about 20
countries in europe this is in january
to may 2012.
graduated college in economics and
entrepreneurship did not want to do the
corporate american nine-to-five job so i
took a job as an english teacher in
south korea which was a great move for
me to kind of
start a new life in asia and through my
two years in korea i also went to about
20 to 25 countries in asia and i was 23
years old when i left korea and i
thought
well i've been to about 50 countries why
not try to go to all them so i have a
mentor named lee abbamonti who at the
time was the youngest american to visit
every country and he finished at 31. so
here i am at you know 23 24 i'm 50
countries in and so i said i have seven
years to try to break his record and i
did but now i'm not the youngest
american i'm like the third youngest
american to visit every country wow did
someone beat you how did someone be they
they jumped in at the last minute and
now there's some damn 28 year old with
the world's record and you're sitting
there going well then what was the point
in any of it
no no no no it's not a race it's not a
race it's uh it's been an incredible
journey
drew drew
it's a race and you lost and you lost
it's a race that you lost true is what
we're trying to say all right well i'm
not talking to you guys
my question is can we get the world's
youngest
world traveler on the show are producers
still there
i mean i guess we'll finish the
interview anyway
we're here we might as well
uh drew this is so exciting you know
like uh we talked about this a lot at
the top of the show travel is very
important to both of us
um you know in our in my household it's
it's it's a value like it's literally a
family value and i just wonder like when
you were growing up
um did you did you come from a family
that instilled this idea
on you like you know be a global citizen
see the world you know understand what
other people think and and empathize
with all these or was this just kind of
like
suddenly it happened because you went on
a study abroad and you realized oh this
is the this is the kind of person i want
to be definitely the latter i was raised
jewish i had a bar mitzvah and and i was
told at a young age that muslims are not
the friendliest people in the world i
mean that's well that's truthfully
what i thought no muslims are great
i love them i love islam so uh i was a
sheltered you know white you know i you
could say privileged um upper middle
class raised in arizona and my eyes just
opened up
from really going to europe for the
first time i traveled a little bit as a
kid i played competitive hockey and golf
so i was uh traveling around the country
mostly canada mexico and we took some
family trips to the bahamas and stuff
like the classic american caribbean
destinations but never really overseas
uh to europe or asia or africa or south
america so it was really study abroad
that changed my whole perspective and
flipped my world upside down and and i
just
became obsessed with connecting with new
people learning about new cultures and
figuring out our purpose for for being
here so
i just went with it i want to back up a
little bit hockey and golf and i was
just thinking
you specialize in sports where they hit
balls with sticks
now did you ever see that did you ever
see that that documentary about that guy
that golfed his way across mongolia
that sounds so cool i have not
you mean like you mean like you just hit
a hit a golf ball from one side of
mongolia to the other side from one side
of mongolia to the other i swear yeah um
i don't remember any of the details but
did you ever put those ball and stick
skills um to use in some weird sport in
some part of the world
i have played cricket which is an
interesting sport and a lot of americans
just don't get it but it's really really
popular there's americans who do not get
it yeah i do not get it in india and
pakistan it's like a religion out there
so i did participate in cricket uh just
a tangent i'll tell you my problem with
cricket
in case okay and then then can i tell
you my problem with both hockey and golf
when you're done why not let's talk
about sports i mean truth is in mind uh
please here's what i don't get about
cricket you go to sleep
and it's australia 379
to india 7 and you're like okay well
that that game's over right and you wake
up the next morning and it's like india
won what
how
how do you make up three hundred and
seventy points
any sport
they all bat at one so think about
baseball like the home team will bat all
nine innings and then the away team will
bat all nine innings that's how they do
it so you are right it is very strange
how it works
well that's the first time anyone's ever
explained it to me that means okay okay
but hockey
hockey is the only sport in the world
where they stop the game
to allow people to start punching each
other
i think they i think they stop either
that they need to they need to ban that
or they need to include that little
facet of hockey into every other
sport like tennis
where you stop the game and you jump the
net and you just start pounding on each
other and the ref is there just making
sure no one else is jumping let them get
their punches in then it's like okay now
that's enough now go back and continue
the game
no one knows what you're looking for in
a doctor better than you and no one is
better at giving you the tools to find
the perfect doctor than zoc doc
the people who created zocdoc found the
major pain points in health care all the
things that weren't working and they
said you know what enough and they made
booking a great doctor surprisingly
pain-free so zocdoc is a free app that
shows you doctors who are patient
reviewed take your insurance and are
available when you need them so read up
on local doctors get verified patient
reviews and see what other real humans
had to say about their visit so go to
zocdoc.com
that's right
zocdoc.com
choose a time slot and whether you want
to see the doctor in person or just do a
video visit you can do either and just
like that your book
find the doctor that's right for you
book an appointment that works for your
schedule every month millions of people
use zocdoc and i'm one of them it's my
go-to whenever i need to find and book a
doctor
in the chaotic world of healthcare let
zockdoc be your trusted guy to find a
quality doctor in a way that is
surprisingly pain free with sockdoc you
can get your docs in a row i get it go
to zocdoc.com milkshake and download the
zocdoc app for free then start your
search for a top-rated doctor today many
are available within 24 hours that's
dot zocdoc.com slash milkshake
zocdoc.com
milkshake
you know actually it sounds like we're
off the the point
but
dear listeners this is just the genius
of the metaphysical milkshake because in
a sense drew's explanation
of both you know uh hockey and uh
cricket
is kind of the point of all this right
because there are so many benefits
to being a well-traveled
person right and i don't mean like
intellectual benefits so you understand
how cricket works that's nice but there
are like actually literally health
benefits
to this right
so for instance uh there was a cornell
university study that said that uh
people experience a direct increase in
happiness just from planning a trip
which i'm gonna i might have to yell
[ __ ] about because i've like i plan
trips that's like no
that's not the most happy part of a trip
but okay fine uh there have been a
number of studies that have uh
investigated links between creativity
and international travel
there was one study that said that three
days after taking a vacation
travelers report feeling less anxious
more rested and in a better mood
i would probably assume that these are
people who traveled without children but
okay nevertheless but but reza there's
there's another uh study here that i saw
that was is fantastic there was a study
of 46 dutch workers that found that
after going on an international holiday
for two to three weeks
when they came back they were able to
generate more diverse ideas for
alternative ways to use everyday objects
such as bricks tires spoons pencils etc
so before they left they did a test you
know what can you do with a brick and a
pencil or whatever all of a sudden they
go on a two-week vacation travel and
they're more imaginatively able to use
common objects which shows that their
brain has been opened up in some
significant new ways see okay so drew
you you're like the perfect guinea pig
for these kinds of uh
experiments
what have you personally discovered to
be like the benefits i don't we'll talk
about intellectual benefits emotional
benefits but i mean i'm talking about
like literally health benefits
uh to traveling like how has it
altered your life
i think everything you guys just said is
spot on when you think about the typical
american lifestyle you know you get up
in your house go to work which is the
same building or it's in your house now
you go probably eat at the same 10
restaurants and then you go to bed and
it's just so familiar and it's just
repetition repetition repetition when i
travel
everything is new and exciting i'm using
different parts of my brain that i never
knew existed i'm constantly problem
solving
i just went to belize two days ago and i
met the president his name is johnny
briseno
he's the second president i've met in
the last six months the other was in
palau and it was fascinating just to sit
down with him but
and i can get into that later but just
the challenge of logistically going to
to
figure out how i'm going to meet him and
i did a whole youtube video about it was
so rewarding and it's just something
that
i'm using parts of my brain that i
wouldn't normally use and constantly
meeting new people
sharing stories um
relying on the kindness of others to
help out and that's one of the you know
the biggest takeaways i've had around
the world is that 99.999 of people are
good people they're welcoming they're
friendly they they genuinely want to
meet you and share their culture with
you in the same way that if somebody
if a friend of a friend of a friend
called you up and and they wanted to go
visit you in la or wherever you live you
would be so happy to take them a couple
places because you're proud of it it's
the same thing you know and so i'm sorry
i'm not i'm not proud
i don't know that reza and i are very
proud of example
okay where are you originally from rain
uh seattle
great i was just in seattle too i'm
looking at wedding venues up there um
yeah we're actually looking at snow
quality which is like 30 minutes oh yeah
i love scratch i know yeah it's great
beautiful seattle if somebody if one of
your best friends had another friend
that said hey and you happen to be in
seattle you would love to take them to a
couple places i would be proud to show
them around the emerald city thank you
very much love it yes great so it's kind
of the same thing people are genuinely
friendly and welcoming and that's um and
that's the most beautiful thing and and
but you don't get those experiences if
you just stay home because you have your
same friend group and you're just not
stepping out of your comfort zone it
sounds so cliche those words step out of
your comfort zone but the best things
happen when you do step out of your
comfort zone and just go somewhere and
meet someone so that's really why i
can't stop traveling i reach my goal to
go to every country but but now i
realize how little i've seen of the
world you know
russia is huge china is huge india is
huge brazil
so i just i'm gonna start going to
regions and places that i haven't been
like i just got back from iran a few
months ago and i tackled four different
regions of that country that i hadn't
seen on my first trip so it's just an
ongoing amazing process
wow that's that i never really thought
about that you've been to countries but
of course you know
you know i had a friend who went to
vietnam
and a couple of times and he said like
northern vietnam is its own
kind of world and especially if you go
inland it's just
crazy tribes and cultures and completely
different food than the rest of vietnam
so people say like oh i went to vietnam
but you know if you really want to be a
world traveler you're talking about
three or four trips to each country drew
there's still world records to be broken
out there
no but he's right it's like it's like uh
you know visiting wisconsin and being
like i've been to america exactly right
that actually is a good place if you're
going to say you're going to america
wisconsin is that i guess wisconsin is
not too bad you could do milwaukee and
then madison and then you could visit
some farm but you know what what drew's
really talking about here is empathy
isn't he i mean it's
i mean this is a
just a
well trod fact right that
travel
is like an empathy making
experience you know when you see people
from other parts of the world when you
experience how they live what they eat
uh their their rituals and their
traditions
um it just whether you're tr you don't
want it to or not it increases your
empathy it uh
helps you to to suspend judgment about
people regardless of you know whatever
their surface quality is age sex race
ethnicity whatever um
that's that's really the the most sort
of magical part about traveling isn't it
is that it it increases the ability to
see the world from someone else's point
of view
absolutely and you're thrown into those
situations that you're forced to
learn five words in the local language
or else you're not gonna be able to
communicate with someone so you're just
constantly learning and adapting to
different places cultures experiences
and of course you know you learn a lot
about religions about places and the
cool thing is anytime i turn on a movie
an old movie that i've seen and there's
a reference like and i'm like wow i've
been there i know exactly what they're
talking about that's where before i just
it just goes over your head
now you were talking about this
uh i love that reza what you said it's
an empathy building machine to travel
and i think this is such an issue in
america because i don't know what the
statistics are maybe they're on our
little
producers fact sheet there maybe someone
can look it up but
you know the number of the percentage of
americans that not only have never
traveled but don't have a passport or
have never had a passport is astounding
and i do think that culturally
we have a great deal of empathy for
people that live within 100 miles of us
but it's so hard for americans
especially to have empathy for
disasters that happen overseas and you
know and the the strifes and and
troubles and uh you know vicissitudes
that people have to face all over the
globe and
we're really lacking in that department
have you bumped up against this in your
videos and comments on your videos and
why do you think that is that americans
are
so not prone to travel yeah in fact
before you answer drew uh i i don't
remember it is you're right it's a very
small percentage but i do remember this
i remember in 2000
when george w bush became president
uh i read a piece that said he had been
to mexico and canada uh by the way my
the producer um safa thank you for
texting um
a third of americans have never traveled
abroad
that's cray-cray yep it's exactly what i
thought 65 of americans do not have
passports last time i checked it's
somewhere around that number
the reason is a couple things one um
america's so big it's the third largest
country in area and there really is a
lot of places to go if you want
mountains you got mountains beaches um
you know palm trees you got national
parks forests if you want rain go to
seattle um so we and we have so many
diasporas around the country if you want
to meet iranians go to la and you can go
eat persian food authentic persian food
if you want to eat korean food then just
go to koreatown in new york or l.a so i
think that's
part of the reason is because we're such
a melting pot of cultures that we have
a lot of things at our disposal not to
mention hawaii which is a pacific island
american samoa which you can go with
just your id puerto rico so there's also
those places too um
and
we don't really we don't learn languages
i mean okay maybe some of us know
spanish maybe some of us know french go
anywhere in europe those people know
five languages minimum
minimum and it's so normal to cross
borders if you grew up in europe or
anywhere in asia i mean it's just it's
so easy if you're from singapore that
country is this you can walk around
singapore in one day so of course you're
going to be more cultured so that's part
that's the biggest reason i think why
americans don't travel so speaking of
this empathy-making machine the world of
travel and americans and traveling and
you grew up a jewish boy you heard not
so good things about muslims but you've
been to so many muslim countries and
arab states and places that are super
hard to get to we'll get to iran in a
minute because i really want to hear
about it but um
what was that like for you to have a new
experience of islam and muslims in a way
that it must have been just staggeringly
eye-opening because i think so many even
just not even jewish americans
mid-americans are filled with all kinds
of stigmas we only get kind of a lot of
times really stereotyped images of
muslim americans in the media and you
you know a lot of
you know 24 with jack bauer fighting
terrorists and and whatnot and has have
a very limited uh understanding but in
the scope and breadth of that world what
was that transformation like for you and
your heart
great question i i almost felt like i
was reborn i remember
my first time in istanbul in 2012 i saw
a woman who was wearing all black
including her uh hands covered and she
only showed her eyes and and i literally
paused and i had to comprehend because
i'd never seen that before and she was
just totally accepted in the society and
then just the more i traveled around
muslim countries the funny thing is
is that
judaism and islam are so similar we're
literally brothers and we can this is a
whole separate podcast i'm sure but from
my experiences you know we both fast uh
you know got ramadan and yom kippur
friday night is the holy night of prayer
we both believe in one god we both wear
small hats on our heads we're both very
hospitable
over
you know
giving food and and you know giving
sadaka which is giving um
don't donation which is really important
and we both have
mothers who do nothing but give guilt
exactly just for everything guilt guilt
guilt the more time the more time i
spend with with muslims and i've been
invited into homes and and all kinds of
stuff around the world i just re i feel
like i'm in a jewish home and that's
that's a beautiful thing honestly and so
and also not to mention arabic in hebrew
uh shalom alechem or salam alaikem means
may peace be upon you you also read the
dialects from right to left and a lot of
the vowels and characters are the same
so come on it's literally the same so
that's something that i would have never
known or ever thought about if i didn't
go physically and meet people and that's
something i try to communicate in my
videos i've done many many many videos
about you know i'm jewish but i love
islam and what are the similarities and
differences
so that's something that i really love
but yeah to answer your question rayne i
feel like
way more understanding and i feel way
more involved in islam
ramadan just happened i went to the only
muslim majority town in america it's
called hamtramck michigan it's a suburb
of detroit and i made a video about uh
having ramadan and having iftar breaking
the fast and that video already has over
a million views on on youtube i posted
about two weeks ago
i love it i love it and i'm just trying
to communicate that muslims are
amazing people hospitable people and you
know
it's really unfortunate that that the
reputation of the religion is judged on
just a few uh extremists it's really sad
and they're good podcast hosts i've
heard i've heard they make very good
podcast hosts they're great they're
great uh with their they're great
sidekicks
we make very good stuff
yeah
there's only two billion of them only
two billion well i love i love that you
use your travel to build bridges yeah
yeah and yeah and you know
again it's just like we we just keep
coming back to this issue of empathy
right this issue of you know i never get
tired of saying this that bigotry is not
the result of ignorance people say that
all the time oh if you're a bigot or
you're racist it's just because you're
ignorant no no it's not there are some
extremely well knowledgeable
racists out there bigotry is a result of
fear
and fear is impervious to information
fear is impervious to data the only way
to dispel fear is through relationships
right the only way to dispel bigotry to
to fight back against prejudice is
through relationships you just got to
get to know people can you think of like
a place that you've been or an
experience that you've had or or
something that you've witnessed that
really kind of put this empathy thing to
a test you know like something that was
just so
bonkers so out there so
weird that it really like tested you to
be like okay all right i'm gonna
i'm gonna be
i'm gonna put on my empathy hat and just
kind of go with it and and this is this
is a an avenue through which i'm going
to open my mind and get to know
uh a different culture or a different
experience and is there i'm sure there's
tons but is there one that comes to mind
got a great one for you and thanks for
the question reza so
central african republic
one of the hardest countries to get a
visa to one of the hardest countries to
visit because there's one or two flights
a week very dangerous very dangerous
country big uh
yeah it was it was one of my last 20-ish
countries so i went to the capital of
bangi and i met a local guy named david
who i met through instagram and that's
i'm very spontaneous i basically meet
people through instagram i just post up
hey guys i'm gonna be in these five
countries over the next two weeks is
anybody around would love to hang out
and that's how i met him just pure
spontaneity david picked me up at the
airport
and we were going around the city which
was nothing that special but i really
wanted something deeper in the culture
so i knew about the pygmy tribe are you
guys familiar with the pygmies
sure
genetically they're the world's shortest
people on average they're about four
foot four the adults and they live only
in the jungles of central africa so that
includes gabon that includes central
african republic and a little bit of the
congo it might be one other country but
they just live there in little
settlements so i knew the pygmies were
out there in central african republic
and i really wanted to
learn about them and experience their
life so we hired a driver we drove seven
hours from bengi into a small village we
had to bring a hitchhiker on because he
spoke the local language and he said you
have to go through the trees there's no
more roads anymore we ended up stopping
the car and we all had to walk two hours
in the hottest most humid place you
could possibly imagine i didn't even
have enough water on me and we're
slashing through trees that are up to my
neck so we're walking for two hours
there were points in there where i was
like i don't know if i'm gonna make it i
might have to go back to the car so
finally
we we arrive at these small little huts
and there's a community of about 50
pygmies the moment i showed up they
literally looked at me as if i was a
complete alien and i was to them because
when i sat down with i spent 24 hours
with them they told me they had never
seen a white person before ever and it
was really humbling and at the end you
know i ended up i gave them huge hugs
goodbye and it was emotional to leave
them that's how close we had gotten over
those 24 hours but there was one thing
that happened
that really tested my
you know
my
understanding of the of life really is i
witnessed
the the chief
uh with a bow and arrow
kill a gazelle which is a small antelope
i witnessed it he killed it uh arrow got
him and within 20 minutes he had
he had skinned out he had cut it open
with a knife and he had skinned it out
and put it over a fire and that fed the
entire village of 50 people wow he
offered it to me i said no i had my own
snacks and i just i didn't really i
normally i would eat it but it was their
food and it was just so it gives me the
goosebumps telling the story because it
was just so
humble it was so humbling to stand there
and they were so happy and there was a
campfire and they were laughing telling
jokes and it was just
unbelievable experience to be there and
then they ended up dancing around the
campfire the whole night i have a video
on youtube you guys can watch it was
probably my favorite story ever and um
my local guide who we picked up on the
car he had brought some palm wine which
is wine that grows in the trees and
it comes from the nearby town which they
don't get to drink often so they we
brought them all palm wine and they were
all drinking all night just having a
blast uh beating the drums and i was
sleeping on the floor with a little
mosquito nut that i wrapped around a
tree branch and that was just one of the
coolest moments of my life to be there
and uh there's a lot more to unpack of
what happened but that i think that's a
good story to answer your question wow
that is that is good and um but one
thing caught my attention which was you
were talking about them telling jokes
did the translator was he able to
translate a pygmy joke
i really want to know
what a pygmy joke would sound like oh
man a pigment how many gazelles does it
take to screw in a light bulb i don't
know
okay well no but they they really are
one with nature and they play like hide
and seek in the trees and they get they
just like you just turn a corner and
you're gone because it goes up as i told
you to your neck yeah a lot of the kids
are running around and and just like
they just like if you go to a classroom
of of 10 year olds or throwing stuff
around the classroom it's the same kind
of uh experience that i had but i wish i
would i wish i could learn a pygmy joke
or two you know there's there is a
question that comes up when we think
about international travel and i'm
trying to increase my empathy to
uh some of the listeners out there
and
and i do wonder and sometimes i uh have
to remain conscious of this myself
because i am extremely privileged as a
as a white male from america with a big
bank account because i was on a tv show
i'm able to travel
a lot of people are not able to travel
because it's super expensive and you
have to have a certain level of
privilege in order to undertake
international travel and if you're
living in the um
you know on the rosebud indian
reservation you probably don't have
those resources but also there are other
kind of privileges that that rear their
ugly heads when it comes to travel you
know there's certain races
you know if you're
you know if you're african-american
there's going to be places that where
you're treated
perhaps even more poorly than you're
treated in the united states i don't
even know but
you know gender issues if you're trans
if you have a single woman traveling by
herself it's quite different than a
single male traveling
by himself religion
a gay partnership or something like that
so
what can you address around this this
idea that we have to be you know
there is a certain sense of privilege
that comes along with our stories as
world travelers
there's absolutely a sense of privilege
and it's something that i've come to
realize when i left the american bubble
and a lot of americans
just don't realize it because we have so
much here i mean the poorest american is
the richest in many other countries and
that's something that you would only
realize if you went and you know my
passport allows me to visit 186
countries without needing to get a visa
that's crazy countries and territories
deanna my wife is from the philippines
she can only visit 66 countries without
needing to get a visa and actually right
now she's been having issues to get a
european visa which is crazy but she's
very qualified and very educated and
runs her own business so
it's not fair it's not fair that other
people have to nobody can choose where
they're born
um reza i mean i'm sure some of your
family might have iranian passports and
oh yeah that's not going to get you very
far maybe
it's not even that it's like my american
passport says that i was born in iran
and that
has caused me no end of trouble it's an
american passport i'm an american
but it says born you're not
and but you're not exactly so it's
something that you know you can't
re you can't appreciate your own culture
until you travel and realize that wow we
have it so good we have it so good
and i'm not worried about bombs hitting
my house but when i went to bed in libya
in tripoli the capital i was going to
sleep to the sound of bombs that were 10
miles 10 miles away because i was in a
civil war and literally my bed was
shaking like this like vibrating loudly
i don't i take this very very seriously
i mean i i talk so much about we have
we've all been talking so much about how
important travel is and all the enormous
benefits health benefits emotional
intellectual benefits how it changes you
as a human being how it's it's you know
such a vital part of creating empathy
and knowledge of the other and all of
that stuff but we're not gonna lie and
say that it's something that's open to
everyone obviously you know travel is
not
cheap
but i i just want to say one thing um i
didn't become an american citizen until
i was 23
right
and so i was in this country for uh 16
years 16 years is not a citizen
and so i could never leave i could never
leave um but
and i was also dirt poor um
but i
made it my goal
to at the very least see every state
in the union you know and i knew i could
do that i had a shitty car and i could
just drive you know from you know one
state to the next and just the very
least experience that so
i i
understandably here we are three very
privileged people talking about how
important travel is we get it we get it
but i also want to say that travel
doesn't necessarily mean
going to mogadishu although go if you
can right it can mean going to
scottsdale although
you know anyway
which i've been to very cultural here
and it's wonderful it's a wonderful
place it's so beautiful
yeah um it's i went to yogurtland
in uh
in scottsdale so that's like visiting
two countries because i was in
scottsdale but then i went to this
magical land
called yogurt yogurtland yes where
there's like 50 different flavors of
yogurt
all of this is to say
that
understanding you know how how what a
privilege it is to be able to leave this
country
uh at the same time if you're someone
out there you know who's got that bug
you know there you can make it happen
you can make it happen get get you can
get work in other places you can travel
around the united states we were just
talking earlier about like how
incredibly weird and diverse this
country is like the idea that like miami
and seattle are in the same country is
bizarre to me
like how are those two in the same exact
how is new orleans
and madison
the same country
you know on that point it's really funny
because deanna's from the philippines
but there's only one time zone in the
philippines so she still gets confused
she's like wait new york is three hours
ahead not to mention there's one there's
one climate in the philippines she never
had a jacket growing up ever because in
the middle of the winter which if you
count it as a winter it's the same as
the summer the summer just rains a
little bit more so yeah it's crazy to
think about how big the u.s is but
there's also seven thousand islands in
the philippines so to your point you
could travel domestically you could go
to the next island you could meet the
next group of people if you're from
india in that rose field that you that
one of you guys said oh my god you could
get on a train for three dollars and go
to the other you know 10 hours away and
find a different language in a different
india as a continent yeah so you could
definitely travel domestically and i
encourage it
so drew one country that's come up a
bunch of times in our conversation is
iran obviously
born in iran iranian refugee
uh some big issues with iran and when we
were talking about privilege earlier i'm
realizing like
my only uh hesitation of traveling
pretty much anywhere in the world is
is iran being a member of the baha'i
faith because for those of you who don't
know the baha'is are
horribly mistreated in iran and
occasionally randomly jailed and their
rights taken away they're not allowed to
go to university it's this kind of like
uh a persecution that most people in the
world have not heard of it's the largest
religious minority in in iran somewhere
around half a million baha'is in that
country and i wouldn't literally feel
safe going there
knowing you know
being a baha'i or being a well-known
baha'i but at the same time you've said
in so many of your videos how much you
love the country
you know tell us what it is about iran
that that sparks you and what what you
want people to know about the place
because i certainly wish i could go
iran is a country of contrasts um
you know the political system is
garbage but a lot of countries have a
terrible political system and that's not
a reason that i
love or hate a country i really just try
to connect with people and culture and
tradition
and
iran has so much of that it's literally
the birthplace of humanity i mean it's
it's where east meets west it's where
ideas were spread and shared it's where
right next to mesopotamia where
literally the first humans the first
settlements were ever created and
there's so much history along the silk
road that you learn about from going to
iran but just the the deeply rooted
hospitality of iran is unparalleled it's
unmatched to any other country
you could have zero dollars in your
wallet and walk around iran and easily
find a ride find a house to sleep in and
they will like beg you to sleep in their
house and it's actually kind of annoying
you're like yeah
we could talk about taro for
non-iranians uh it's basically this like
over-the-top hospitality and it's like
it makes you feel uncomfortable it makes
you feel uncomfortable yeah yeah and
you're laughing because you know that
it's true and i'm i have a video coming
by the way my next series in youtube is
all about iran these next five videos i
have a whole thing about taro so i'll
send it to you when it's out but um like
when they open the door for you like
they insist you go for it like that kind
of stuff but um
so but it's great as a tourist it makes
you feel really comfortable and and iran
is safe and it's just incredible there's
so many different regions so many so
many different experiences and it's very
it's very safe
and
you know iran is just a special place
because we hear so many bad things about
it on the media and yes you know iranian
government does not like the us
government if you go in tehran to the
old u.s embassy before 1979 there's
still graffiti in and there's a picture
right now there was a graffiti of the
statue of liberty that was burned in one
hand and being shot in the rib with a
gun and then there was you know
the dollar bill that was like there was
a knife going through george
washington's face like i literally just
saw that like two months ago so
that's still there and and that's part
of it but
iranians love america oh my god do
iranians love americans oh my god they
won't stop talking about it they will
like kiss my feet when they when i tell
them american and they won't believe it
yeah they won't believe it so every
american who's ever visited iran has
come back with that story where it's
like you're very timid
you're really timid and you're like i'm
from america and then the next thing you
know
it's like you are brad pitt you know
yeah
like people
just come on like hundreds of people
gather around they
people don't know
iranians
love
americans just love american music
american food american television
american movies just everything about
america
iran is a country of contrast in the
sense that the government is called the
islamic republic of iran but i went
during ramadan on my first trip and let
me tell you something
nobody fast yeah nobody that i met fast
it's weird especially the younger
generation it's like the least religious
population and they they drink i went to
an underground party and i couldn't
document it because i would never be
able to go back to iran but i've never
seen people drink vodka faster in my
life than an underground party in tehran
and the way they dance with their hands
and they just they badmouth the
government it's just but but women it's
the only country that women have to
cover their hair in saudi arabia
the women by law don't have to cover
their hair but in iran it's still a law
and women cannot sing
in public they can't sing right they
can't play instruments in pub it's just
so it's so sad uh it's really really sad
and to be a baha'i i actually traveled
with a baha'i obviously i can't name him
but just a few months ago and he was
telling me that there's no baha'i
temples in iran because you can't you'll
go to prison or you'll be hanged in
public and but there's a lot of
gatherings but they're just in private
homes so he'll go to a home with 50
people and it's literally like a high
temple but it's in someone's home but if
they get caught if somebody tells them
if the neighbor tells on them then they
could all be persecuted so i would agree
with you rain i would probably not go
there just because of how well known you
are and how outspoken you are about the
baha'i faith and it's just really sad
yeah really really so for people who are
wondering about this so the baha'i are
an unprotected people in iran and what
that means is that
they have no legal recourse
so in other words a baha'i can't you
know bring uh like an uh you know law
accusation against someone a baha'i
can't be a witness in a trial a baha'i
doesn't have any rights at all like any
legal rights at all it's a really
horrible situation but
again
you're you know you're talking about the
the government and this goes right back
to the whole point of this conversation
right you go to iran and you come back
and then the next time you hear
some
you know jack hole uh in dc talking
about
uh bombing iran or that iran is you know
this evil nation
you can say to yourself no but i've
actually been there and everything that
you are saying is wrong and you haven't
uh and that's that's what this is the
whole thing is about so i i want to kind
of end it with
um this question
which i'm sure you're asked all the time
but it really
is the the sort of the the climax of you
know this conversation which is okay so
you've
been to every country in the world
what would you say
is kind of the the greatest lesson
that you have come away from this
experience uh seeing all these people
seeing all these cultures seeing the
difference between a population and its
government seeing the way that other
people
live and die eat and make friends and
you know all of these things worship
you're now 30 years old
what can you say is kind of the greatest
lesson that you have learned from your
experience
my answer is something that almost any
traveler would say and it's just the
truth and for someone who hasn't
traveled i hope this would inspire you
it really is about humanity it is that
all humans are the same doesn't matter
our race doesn't matter our religion
everybody wakes up in the morning we
have to get breakfast we need to make
money to put a roof over our head
if you're a parent you probably take
your kids to school um you cry you laugh
you love you want to feel loved in
return and
that's something i've realized
everywhere in north korea i i joined a
tennis match on the street it was a
tennis court and i picked up i love
sports i love hitting balls as rain
would say and so i literally went to a
tennis court and i was having a freaking
match in north korea with it was a four
it was two two and two so the four
people on the court and that was great
and then at the end they we shook hands
had a big smile and then i walked away
so
yeah they live in this crazy oppressive
regime and they have no idea what's
happening outside in the outside world
they don't have internet but they're
humans they have emotions and that's the
biggest thing and another note is that
everybody smiles in the same language
i've been to so many places where like
the pygmy tribe where they don't even
speak
even even my friends from central
african republic don't speak their
language but but you can you can feel
someone you can smile you can say hi if
you're really hungry you can communicate
that you're hungry to every single
of the eight billion people in the world
you can connect with and that's the
biggest takeaway i've had we're all the
same yes there's some a lot of rich
people a lot of poor people um but you
know if you go to a dinner table
anywhere whether you're in mauritania
and eating with your hands and there's
flies all over the food and you can see
the goat's testicle on your plate which
is actually something that happened or
you're in beverly hills in the biggest
mansion you're still
realizing that all humans are the same i
can't stress that point enough we're all
the same
we're all the same we are all the same
and drew i really
applaud not only your exploits but the
way that you use it to share such a
positive message about the the essential
oneness the unity of humanity and
one of the things that uh is so
important for us americans i think to
understand is that there is a beauty and
diversity that the diversity of humanity
across the globe is a good thing it's a
positive thing we're different heights
we're different skin colors we eat in
different ways we celebrate we dance in
different ways we have different
priorities and this is not uh a weakness
uh this is a strength so the the
diversity and the essential oneness that
you kind of underline in every one of
your videos
is really inspirational you're doing a
great job um and this was just so much
fun having this conversation it really
was it really was thank you so much
drewbinski
uh tell us where we can find you uh on
instagram and uh tiktok thank you guys
so much for this opportunity i feel like
we're just getting started in the
conversation unfortunately we gotta end
uh it's at drubinsky d-r-u-w-b-i-n-s-k-y
on all social medias i uh
just crossed the 10 million follower
mark across the channel so i'm just
gonna keep keep growing it and keep
trying to inspire people and share
the lessons i've learned
and ran that was beautiful what you just
said about diversity is amazing because
it is that's the reason why i can't stop
i just wanna i wanna meet more people
that don't look like me
you know so
guys it was so much fun thank you
drew it was an honor thank you for
coming on the show
wow what a great conversation what a
cool dude i love his message so much
we're all the same
uh we're all the same i was thinking
about that pygmy story it's just
fantastic and being bombed in libya
um
because you know there is a lot of uh
magnificent glory but there's also a lot
of incredible
challenges on so many levels um
in visiting foreign cultures
and uh have you had any of those he was
talking about some of the difficulties
he underwent has have you ever been to a
place that just
challenged you to the core
i would say i would say um
i went to varanasi in india i spent a a
like a week in varanasi in india which
is like it's it's often known as the
city of the dead because they have these
gats right these like giant funeral
pyres that are they've got it's like
dozens of them and they are going 24 7.
and it's just like
one dead body after another
you know piled onto the onto the uh
fires and like it's just it's
overwhelming like you can't walk through
the city without like ash the ashes of
the dead you know like all over your
clothes of your hair and
and you know i i'd like to think of
myself as a cultural relativist you know
to to each his own
etc but
it's it gets to you after a while to
like be constantly covered in dead
people
uh
that was probably the the weirdest the
hardest uh travel experience that i ever
had what about you i haven't faced
anything so gruesome
but one thing i'll never forget and
there's been a recent spate of violence
in the holy land in israel
which is you know where the baha'i holy
land is
and in jerusalem it's
where the jewish
most holy site is and the muslim second
most holy site and the christian most
holy site they're all within a couple of
soccer fields of each other yeah and uh
one of the things that i'll never forget
and i and i took a picture of it i need
to find it um we visited jerusalem about
10 years ago and we're at the wailing
wall which is right next to the al-aqsa
mosque which is right next to the church
of the holy sepulchre
and there was a little jewish kid with a
yamaka
on standing next to the wailing wall
with a
gigantic plastic
submachine gun
um uh-huh
um kind of
pretending to be a guard or
it dwarfed him
and it just broke my heart um
i'm not gonna take any kind of political
stand on this right now but
it broke my heart that we're in such a
situation where
uh about seven meters from the holiest
jewish spot on earth there's a jewish
kid with a i mean a three and a half
foot long plastic uzi around his
shoulders
and um
that's just was the most was the biggest
kind of visual evidence of like how
upside down things are in the holy land
right now and it it really upset me
frankly and i i still think about it to
this day you know this is a great
question for our milkshakers out there
what about you guys is there
uh a place that you've been that has
really challenged uh your view of the
world and experience that you've had
while traveling that that transformed
you uh for for good or for bad uh some
strange weird moment uh in your travels
that made you really question
uh whether
you had made the right decisions in your
life or not
let us know you can find us on social
media at reza aslan and
rayne wilson we're on twitter at
metamilkpodcast and on instagram at
metaphysicalmilkshake let us know your
life's big question let us know your
your great travel story uh and you know
if you rate us go go to apple podcast or
wherever you listen to podcasts give us
a nice little review and in that review
tell us your travel story maybe we'll
share it with our listeners you can
write us at metaphysical cast media.com
that's cast with k
also subscribe to our youtube channel
please we need some more views we'd love
to
have you there then you get to watch the
interviews which is so much fun
thanks for listening milk shakers we'd
love to hear from you thanks to
drewbinski and safe travels
metaphysical milkshake is executive
produced by rayne wilson reza aslan and
colin thompson
it is produced by safa samazadeh yazd
harris lane mick dimaria hashem self and
dj lubell
cast media is the production and
distribution partner original music by
jeff tang
[Music]
so he became the president of the united
states
and he had only been out of america
once to go to canada and wants to go to
mexico and also mexico he's the governor
of texas
like you cross the street across the
street you're in mexico so that doesn't
count you know it makes it so much
easier to become a war criminal when
you've only been to canada and mexico
hey thanks for watching you guys for
more fantastic videos just like the one
that you watch please subscribe to our
youtube channel thank you